before we go chris you may have noticed
this on your cell phone device or maybe
you did not in cincinnati the effort to
trade andy dalton has concluded
in a failure to trade him he has been
released by the bengals which it's not a
surprise not a shock at all joe burrow
is their guy the bengals avoid 17
million dollars in cash obligation to
dalton and he's on the market now he's
available would it have been better to
be available earlier
probably just like with cam newton and
carolina but he's free and clear he'll
be available and now just like with cam
newton just like with joe flacco we got
to figure out where the hell these guys
are going to land for 2020 if anywhere
well i i the first thing i think of with
andy dalton is to reunite with jay
gruden who drafted him and jay gruden's
the offensive coordinator in
jacksonville right now and you know we
know they have gardner minshew but he's
still a little bit of a question mark
and an unproven commodity to where that
might be a place i would look you know
you know there's a veteran guy that
knows the offense and if gardner
mentioned you know craps down his leg as
for lack of a better word uh then you're
dead or does both sides
or pees the bed whatever it may be then
you have a guy like andy dalton to come
in and save the day but you know i do
think andy dalton you know is going to
find a home to me
quicker than a cam newton because
he's not as threatening as cam newton
again like we've talked about cam
newton's the type of guy that's gonna
players gonna walk off the field and go
damn why isn't he our starter he's
special andy dalton's not necessarily
gonna have that effect
yeah i agree with you and he's not gonna
walk through the door with expectations
to compete to be the starter it's going
to cost less to get him
and and look he's not that this is where
it's a curse to be as good as cam newton
is right if andy dalton was as good as
cam newton he'd have a hard time finding
another job too of course he wouldn't
have been cut possibly by the bengals
and they wouldn't have taken joe burrow
because they wouldn't have been uh
holding the first pick in the draft
because they wouldn't have stunk last
year anyway um i'm look i i'm thinking
of any connection i possibly can marvin
lewis currently isn't in the league he
was the head coach when andy dalton was
drafted so it's not like marvin lewis
could sign him mike zimmer was the
defensive coordinator
in cincinnati for the first few years of
andy dalton's tenure they're back up to
kirk cousins as sean mannion
i it's a different offensive philosophy
all together but i'd kind of like andy
dalton
as a different set of eyes and ears for
kirk cousins not not as a guy who you
would expect to play but just as a guy
who can help cousins you know maybe see
things he doesn't see understand
defensive concepts and elevate his game
mentally do you see any merit to that
i do i definitely do you know i think
his skill set fits that offense there
too so that makes a lot of sense you
know my mind also went right away to
like the los angeles rams you know he's
gonna fit what they do there having just
played under zach taylor's offense he'll
know that he could be a very good backup
for jared goff and then again i'm going
to go back to the pittsburgh steelers
you know the steelers view themselves as
a team that's a super bowl contender do
we want to take the chance of big ben
getting hurt again and going down the
same road we did last year to have to
invent offenses and win games with their
defense on a weekly basis so right off
the bat with a guy like andy dalton i
think of the teams who are in
wow
we have a team right now that can
compete if we lose our quarterback can
we still compete and i think there's a
few out there that i would say no and
andy dalton certainly can bolster those
chances if you got him on your roster
and andy dalton ultimately had five
straight playoff appearances as the
starting quarterback of the bengals they
have fallen on hard times since then
they never won a playoff game under andy
dalton but still he was not a horrible
quarterback and i'm reminded of
a comment that was made in the in the
media
um
back before dalton was drafted out of
tcu in the second round in 2011.
a coach asked an unnamed coach asked a
member of the media back before the
draft has there ever been a red-headed
quarterback in the nfl who's really done
well it sounds idiotic but is there any
way that could be a factor we've
wondered that so uh yeah andy dalton has
done pretty well for himself despite the
color of his hair but that just shows
you how ridiculous this process can
ultimately be how about the uh a couple
of other possibilities houston texans
who have aj mccarron as the backup
kansas city chiefs with chad henne as
the backup tennessee titans logan
woodside is number two to ryan tannehill
there definitely i think that makes a
lot of sense i mean the tennessee titan
ones for sure
i look at that and go that makes sense
that's smart you know i i again i think
there's gonna be a big mark
because i think there's too many of
these teams who who have underwhelming
quarterback situations
where this guy's gonna be able to help
so uh you know i think those are a few
good ones that i would look at right off
the bat let alone i'm even the dallas
cowboys i'm thinking about andy dalton
you know you know
yeah and i'm trying to think of somebody
else i was going to say atlanta falcons
i would i don't know what their deal is
with that shop or what they're trying to
do but that would be another team again
that i feel like he could go in and run
that offense and if the quarterback did
get hurt they're not going to fall off
too much
how about blaine gabbard is to back up
to tom brady in tampa bay
well he's certainly going to make you
feel more comfortable
right i mean gabbard has done an okay
job as a backup but yes he's not andy
dalton you know yeah like you said mike
we've kind of disrespected andy dalton
he's had a better career that you know
we want to all give him credit for it's
just he's not like a cream of the crop
type quarterback i think he's one of
those guys that if he's your starter you
always go he's good but we're looking
out of the corner of our eye
right now for somebody better that's the
kind of guy he is so uh and i saw pete
dim a little lighter light of light us
he uh texted us the seattle seahawks you
know that's a good thought too i i still
thought geno smith was under contract up
there but that would make ch that would
make sense if not that andy dalton to go
up there so their season's not ruined if
any if russell wilson had a high ankle
sprain or something like that
yeah currently the depth chart on the
seattle seahawks roster at quarterback
is one russell wilson that's it so they
need somebody at some point and hey
maybe maybe they they were just waiting
for andy dalton i mean look we all knew
this was going to happen they weren't
going to be able to trade that salary
they're not going to pay part of the
salary the bengals aren't going to do
that to try to get a late round draft
pick next year they're going to cut him
they they will and
now we see where he lands next but i'm
with you he's going to land somewhere
before cam newton because he's not a
starter he doesn't have to wait for that
opportunity he'll be someone's back up
and he should probably do fairly well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports